it took over my life to the point where
you know my family paled into
insignificance it ended up costing me my
job it cost me my house it cost me
everything the symptoms of addiction are
painfully familiar and so increasingly
is this man's problem gaming it affected
my work life greatly I was always tired
I didn't want to be at work I would much
rather be at home on a PC it affected my
personal relationships as you can
imagine I didn't have a personal
relationship we were living in the same
house that I had at the time and at the
height of it I had two children had a
partner but you know it was like we were
living separate lives because my life
was sitting in front of the computer
senior MPs have heard the message today
they accused the gaming industry of
failing to tackle addiction I think the
games industry should accept a much more
proactive responsibility it gathers the
data about how people play how much they
spend it can see it can identify the
outliers people who maybe are suddenly
play a lot more or for a long period of
time being playing a lot more and I
think it should take an interest in the
welfare of those players and not leave
it up to the player themselves to
self-refer and say I think I'm playing
too much or leave it to parents or
others I think the games companies who
are making money out of their players
they should do that if she's been
creeping up on gaming companies just
last year the World Health Organization
said it was worried about gaming
disorder although when the MPS quizzed
game CEOs they argued that was a
question for doctors we aren't able to
go out and diagnose individuals we
aren't able to go into their home and
tell them how to play I don't think it
is our primary responsibility to
determine how much individual players
should play for them I asked the
recovering gaming addict whether he sees
hope but he's just struggling to stay on
the straight and narrow I really like
gaming it's like I suppose people with
other addictions they like drugs and
alcohol I like being on the PC and the
consoles that's really what if I'm being
honest that's what gets me down the fact
that I can't do it safely
a reminder that gaming's original
purpose was the pursuit of pleasure but
that even that can have its dark side
role amantha Sky News